today has been a bad day I don't know
I'm just frustrated the entire thing
we're just both upset I'm just worried
that all of this is getting to him that
he's like seeing me in a different light
or something it feels like the quality
of the time we're spending together and
going down I don't know how to make
things feel normal again hello
sound rolling sound is rolling uh hi
there I'm aria and I'm rural and
obviously things right now are a little
a little cuckoo bananas a little wild
out there and so I guess we want to do
our part to obviously help with the
social distancing practices going on
right now that work from home orders and
so we want to limit the amount of time
we're traveling back and forth between
our places and so we are going to just
lock ourselves up together now in my
jungle so we're gonna do is probably
seven days then we'll decide if we want
to renew your subscription we're not
gonna be completely alone these seven
days though because we have this little
kitty here Genovese what bro loves all
animals
yes which has taken me into a handyman
she bought a set of wall mounts for the
chief cat so we've been dating for a few
months and you know going from seeing
each other here and there and spending
about a few days together at most to
24/7 for a week straight is gonna be
like going from zero to sixty here is
just this beauty and I can find in a
spot together waking up together eating
together working together if you love
not on camera yeah I'm gonna see how
many times a day this men use the
bathroom I don't use a bathroom wow you
look pretty proud project is complete
the kitty cat can hop up here scamper up
here whoa what's that
I see underneath we'll need to show that
you certainly don't need to show that
then that I mean
miscalculated some of my measurements
from a certain angle you can't see it I
feel like our relationships been pretty
public and there's a lot of pressure
that goes with that with like being a
perfect couple so I think this will be a
good opportunity we put a fee that we
are just human beings here exactly
because I think it will get tough this
week oh I know it will get tough well
people aren't meant to be together 24/7
at all times nobody people that live
together see each other less than him
and I already do because we work
together we're pickling and we're
watching Twin Peaks pickle pickle pickle
pickle pickle pickle pickle spicy the
first time that Ari and I went out to
get some Thai food together he said are
you sure you want extra extra spicy and
I said yes I'm sure I do
and sure enough we got the same thing
Ari I was crying I was totally fine I
was blown away by this white woman
smells like Bo but it will taste
delicious
in just a week's time they wanted is
pretty much over we're gonna just faust
me an array for the night um so far so
good though right
yeah today was a good day I think it's
gonna be hard enough to stay sane as
your own human being let alone with
another person but we're gonna do our
best we'll try to be kind to each other
and we'll be very honest about how this
actually goes questing is something
we've done us for our sanity started
yeah first simple concept yes no I've
got the height advantage exactly exactly
she trained by professional fighters
[Music]
yeah we have work to do today
but some person was a good way to start
the day I'm working on this big project
right now that is the biggest video I've
ever done for BuzzFeed that's very
personal it's sensually like a big
life-changing revelation type video that
eats at my soul every day that I added
it because I have to watch myself crying
every single day it's very stressful and
I can't go outside yeah good night
working from home used to feel like a
snow day and now it's everyday do you
feel like we're more productive I don't
know about you back feeling I get
distracted but easily
it's just watching us yeah probably I
feel very productive I'm making some
vegan tacos I'm cooking for this woman
because she's working hard on a big
project they are cooked meals this man
is talented and he is nice to me yeah I
love this lady it's my song I feel like
I'm not making any progress
and yet I've been editing for 10 hours
straight
imagine watching yourself go through
intense therapy without something
extremely personal and then knowing
thousands of possibly millions of people
will watch it and then trying to be a
normal person and a good girlfriend well
you're doing great
[Music]
we're here actually here to Thai
supermarket getting some bad
these are produce green onions is making
spring rolls I'm vegan this entire week
I just realized you're welcome
we're trying to get out of the house by
any means necessary just going grocery
shopping feels like a luxury because
we're not supposed to be walking around
all the time these are all blurring into
one day so it's nice to kind of take a
little break you know in the day day to
go out put some pants on because I'm not
wearing pants very often never
he's never wearing pants he's constantly
has his buns out she likes it though
yeah they're cute little coconut no we
were rolling we're back home now we're
back at Merle's now okay as well be your
home at this movie we have work for us
today special advice to know
we're feeling lonely a little bit so we
wanted to reach out and see other people
in the world we're filming a video right
now in case you're wondering where we're
Aria and I are kind of in close quarters
together for at least a week
Fernanda wants me to show of my dick
next okay yeah let's do that
ah yeah I'll get follows I'll lose
followers - can we go this is my role
from Murrow oh my gosh yes please Morell
I like that I like that we're now on day
three of our time together for a week
non-stop you know she's been working on
her big project and so I guess it's been
nice talking everyone it's been nice
kind of get a little break away from
everything but I guess it's right back
to it just being the two of us to the
grind
I see Ryan
I think this project is already
difficult and the fact that we're stuck
inside all the time is just amplifying
it times like 20 and very cranky right
now I'm sorry you know what helps what
having a camera on my bigs hmm so uh my
focus I gotta focus I'm making pasta I'm
cooking dinner just so she doesn't have
to worry about that usually when I'm
working on a big project she takes care
of me so you know I just wanna return
the favor we haven't been able to do too
much today
apart from work so hopefully didn't be a
nice kind of like retreat for the moment
hope you like it
that's oh god oh my god this is
absolutely delicious really all perfect
stress food I'm sorry I've been sleeping
cranky it's okay never felt good I hope
it helps I'm gonna eat this whole thing
in five minutes
oh yeah you gotta go back to work well
yeah but I'm actually gonna stop and
enjoy this is so so yummy thank you
ma'am
you're welcome this helps a lot
another man falls victim to Ashley
Madison message it my family okay a
president overseas there in Laos which
currently has been too affected by the
pandemic but obviously you know I'm a
little worried about them are you
stressing out a little bit I think all
obviously offs are worried about our
parents but the fact that my family is
so far away makes it more stressful yeah
you can go back to work you know I don't
worry about me
telling me this stuff filming you yeah
okay okay well so far it's been a little
bit of a bad morning I don't really even
know how to vlog about it but I guess
for the sake of transparency you know I
said I guess this morning I was in the
best mood she want to take a break from
her work and hang out a little bit and
she said you know that my reaction I've
kind of brushed her off I mean I guess
when it comes to this project I'm
frustrated because I see you know how
draining it is for her I want to support
her through it and I just wanted her to
get it done I don't know I guess me
being in a bad mood and me in my eyes
wanting her just to get focus on her
work I kind of brushed her off and you
know obviously she's a little hurt she
was hurt by that and I mean just I don't
know I'm just frustrated the entire
thing
if you want to blog for the video I was
working on my project and I tried to go
over to where ru was sitting on the
couch and like be a little affectionate
with him and be kind of playful because
I feel like I've been just so serious
and so involved with this work and he
just completely iced me out I feel like
he never ever ever ever does that I feel
like I'm kind of stuck between a rock
and a hard place because I'm working
nonstop on this project and Ari is doing
everything right now he can and he's
cooking he's cleaning and I feel guilty
that he's doing all these things but
then like I don't have the energy to be
a good girlfriend at this moment I'm
just worried that all this is getting to
him that he's like seeing me in a
different light or something I feel that
like equal parts guilty and sad we're
just both upset
we both have reasons to be upset that's
the worst part is we both have a right
side of this argument part of me wanted
to just kind of not flog today so we
don't have to show that we're having
this issue or that we're going through
this right now but it would be dishonest
you felt like I didn't show affection
one for me I've been showing affection
in my way for the past few days by you
know cooking and you know cleaning and
these are like I said these are things
you do for me too so you know so I get
that you do appreciate it
I honestly earlier today just needed you
to be there to listen and instead of to
be there to do things yeah I didn't need
you to be there to be my cook or to be
the maid I needed you just to be there
to be you listening to me you feel like
you are doing everything you can to be
supportive I feel like I don't have a
whole lot to give back at this moment
and then I'm not asking you to I know no
I know
and that almost made me feel worse I'm
sorry I was being snappy I mean I'm
sorry that I guess I wasn't I was
assuming what she needed and I thought
what you needed was to get this project
done over with and maybe I was being
selfish to wanted this project I said it
makes me stress to see you stressed and
so my mind like can you get this this
game project done and so I didn't want
to you to take a break in pocket about
adding pressure to the project
ultimately I do believe that it is
unnatural and unfair to place any two
people or more together for 24/7 and
expect things to go smoothly I think if
you hadn't been here all the time there
wouldn't been as much pressure on me all
the time to try to do my job and be your
girlfriend yeah and there wouldn't have
been as much pressure on you to try to
fix it I think the longer we've been
dating - we spend more time together
anyway
and I think it's important that we start
to value our time together it's harder
to do that over together every single
second of every day so it feels like the
quality of the time we're spending
together has been going down because
we're just trying to like do things to
stay sane
so I think we need to try to up the
quality of the time we're spending
together even in these circumstances
since it's the weekend tomorrow I feel
like I can't remember the last time I
took a weekend day I'm gonna just do no
work tomorrow put it aside for now for
one day I think it's important it's more
important to me than the project to be
honest with you so I want to prioritize
you you deserve it any good
tomorrow we'll try to figure out how we
can bring a little bit of normalcy that
our life here you lady love you love
this woman
it's okay everyone we're fine yeah yeah
I just attacked this woman where are you
feeling better
we had a cute make out in the kitchen I
wouldn't call it cute I we call it a HR
inappropriate today is the weekend so
I'm gonna put my work aside for the day
we're gonna spend more quality time
together kind of go back to the way we
used to be when we could leave the
apartment whoa she's blue in my ear
whoa that's doomed ed I'm making a tofu
scramble yes she's not just making
onions romina delicious tofu scramble it
was good pop into them roasted tomatoes
there was like a big table up by the
kitchen things just gonna pile you up on
it and it made his face feel very
cramped so one of the things we decided
today was just pack up the table in the
spirit of being inside all the time I
feel like it's a nice opportunity to
optimize space feels we can breathe more
here and hope it all makes things feel
less cramped today is very productive
day we spent more quality time we were
moving stuff around cause we're open and
less claustrophobic got a good workout
had a good healthy meal
so I feel like we were using a lot of
screens we were looking a lot of screens
whether it was the lady that was editing
her project every night this week okay
so in order to like kind of plug back
into real life we want to try to limit
the amount of screen time we have after
dinner when you're inside all the time I
feel like it's easy to just like get
warped into the outdoor world through
your phone so we want to like enjoy the
moment we're in with each other in real
life we're going to try to tune back
into ourselves more by meditating every
night every night my god that's
terrifying
Oh your hotel we can't booty articles
are done no this is my underwear the
coconut nests so the week is done the
week is that was easy
it was highs and lows it was stressful
but I think you know we learned a lot of
things along the way being in a
situation like this it's difficult for
any pair of people whether you're dating
or not it's like an incubator for a
relationship for a new couple this is
kind of an accelerant all of the things
that you struggle with they're gonna
come forward and be amplified and all
the things that are wonderful about you
guys will come forward to be amplified
so I think it's good to just expect that
and be patient but also be grateful for
the good things you have I think when
you have 24/7 with someone you think oh
now we have all this time together you
know you don't really think you need to
focus on the little things quantity as
time is not quality time just being with
someone does I mean you're giving them
quality time and learn how to ask what
you need it was a big learning
experience but I feel like it's made us
stronger I feel like it's made our bond
stronger instead of dividing us all you
have to do is communicate know me so I
guess the question is do I stay a little
past the 7 days now
oh yeah that's it from us don't think I
think this woman needs socks
[Music]